on today's podcast with a very
interesting and other controversial
guest Logan Paul is joining us man
himself yeah he's been at the center of
a lot of controversy we're gonna ask him
what is that like what is it like being
the heel of the Internet and what does
that what does that do to you personally
yeah how do you deal with that so a lot
of interesting questions here for Logan
he's a very young guy so the amount of
stuff he's dealt with at a young age
I don't think gonna find anybody else in
the planet with the same perspectives
he'll have now you may not like Logan
Paul in fact I can bet pretty highly
that if you're part of the quarter
audience you're not necessarily a huge
Logan Paul fan but listening to people
is not the same as agreeing with them
and I find it fascinating to listen to
all types of perspectives so let's kick
back relax and listen to this
conversation with Logan Paul
so tell me about this documentary like
what do you want to no bro it's the most
important document of our generation
what are you trying to achieve for this
documentary yeah that's a I guess I
really should have thought about that
why my white why did I create this this
documentary uh I mean this year I've
been focused on doing things that
intrigue me
mm-hm and uh this flat earth movement
intrigued me you do you know how much
you know about the Flat Earth I tend to
avoid it honestly because I find I I
feel like the vast majority of people
are doing it to be like ironic and
there's a couple of crazies that
actually believe it I think it's I think
it's the opposite really I think I think
it's there's a lot of people who believe
it and there's a couple people who do it
just to be trolls mm-hmm
and this movement fascinated me so we uh
we went to the Flat Earth conference in
Denver Colorado and man I don't know how
much I can say about this cuz I got to
keep it keep the Conda on the low but we
basically
one with the flat earthers okay and join
their movement okay and and pick their
brains about why they think the earth is
flat and then came to conclusions of her
own which obviously you'll see in the
documentary like you could you could you
two could be sitting in front of a flat
earther right now who knows what do you
attribute like this kind of like I mean
for lack of a better word like anti
science like you know anti-vaxxers and
why is all this stuff rising up right
now yeah so the conclusion I came to was
people people like to feel like they're
a part of a part of a group they like to
be feel like they're a part of something
and I don't know oftentimes people feel
isolated they feel like they don't
belong to anything and the Flat Earth
movement that became a tight-knit
community of people who all believe in
something that in their opinion if it's
true could mean to a greater
understanding of what it means to be a
human and they they they like that
they're attracted towards that and yeah
I don't even know if it's so much about
whether or not they actually believe the
earth is flat is just like being part of
a group mmm-hmm I don't know do you
think there's any sort of like I guess
narcissistic tendency to like feel like
you know something that other people
don't
yeah of course of course that's why I'm
like imagine if you're just like an
outcast in high school or and you grow
up and you're still a kind of an outcast
and like most of these people are as you
can imagine like you you using your
worse call them crazies okay they are
and that's why they fascinate me and so
can you imagine if you're like a crazy
and you look to your right at this
conference and there's like another
crazy there and you look to your left
and there's there's another person who
thinks the same thing as you and you got
that little like understanding of what
you perceive to be real and
know something that the rest of the
world doesn't it's exciting and and I
think they I think they thrive on that
but again I could be talking about
myself crazy maybe I think the earth is
flat all our podcast guests we asked him
we say what do you think the earth is I
was like look at some would say flat one
of them was a flat earther oh yeah yeah
we had a boxer on it he he said the
earth was flat Wow yeah so you go into
this convention and you guys got like
hidden cameras you're like sneaking
sneaking some shooting from the hip kind
of thing or you guys are going in like
first day just to scout it and see
what's up and then know it no hidden
cameras no it's all how no yep yep got
you
there's a there's not much there's no
aspect of like none of it is none of its
fake per se it's all real like we go to
this conference and it's me Logan Paul
filming a documentary mmm-hmm how long
we been working this for so the
conference was damn mid-november when
are you dropping the final problem a dog
the original released it was like
December 1504 so we are [ __ ] behind
um I want it I want to do it as soon as
possible hopefully early February seems
about right I want to drop a trailer
first obviously and I bit up because
like I this is the greatest thing I've
ever made in my life it's uh it's I
think it's if if received properly it
will like send a tidal wave through
YouTube I want to do its Shane it what
Shane does you know you know and Shane
drops whatever anything he's dropping
now everyone shake Dawson knew like
conspiracy serious uh whatever it is and
it pops and if it's received like that
which it should be because it's [ __ ]
incredible yeah that would be nice
that's super interesting man very very
interesting very very interesting yeah I
mean getting getting into someone else's
mind like why do you believe the things
that you believe in like did you just
suddenly wake up and like you know what
I think today you asking me you know I'm
just I'm just kind of asking oh oh oh
and generally if the people of this
convention it's like how did that
start so most that most of them they
start with hearing about it
yeah even some might watch this pot like
us yes no generally so the some people
believe they're at this way exactly and
then you know one day you find yourself
in a rabbit hole on YouTube watching
next Y Z videos and a lot of the
theories make [ __ ] sense is why it's
such a big movement like a lot of the
theories like actually makes sense and
then before you know it I'm sure
something clicks in your brain we were
like wow this like I'm crazy like you're
looking around like this could be
possible like I might actually believe
this then you meet another flat earther
and they're like all gung-ho about it
and before you know it you're [ __ ]
attending the Flat Earth international
conference in Denver Wow what does a I
don't know like you know different
people of different goals and they're
filming documentaries and I don't know
if you're setting out to like challenge
them per se but did you have like did
you have moments where you would like
they would provide a point of view and
you'd try to challenge it with like some
other alternatives oh yeah how do they
react to that like how does somebody
like let's say so they got they got they
got responses to everything well
everything no matter no matter what
scientific evidence you provide them
with they got it they got a B figure it
out and I mean and this is the problem I
think are not a problem this is the
thing is like a lot of the scientific
evidence can be contested one of the
biggest ones like unfortunately is uh
their argument against NASA that every
every picture of the the the round earth
the marble the blue marble is
photoshopped and like you know we can no
no NASA know it's it's NASA like well
why would they lie like no like you bet
you've been lied to for the past a
hundred years and I mean I mean think
about it have you been space I mean if
anyone's been to space this court or
digital up high that's what I'm saying
like but you can see the curvature of
the earth from there
they say you can't well you can you can
see the clouds curve around they say
they say you can't they've done there
you know where the experiments are they
the same kind of people who denied the
Holocaust and deny
moon-landing specifically the moon
landing but yeah I guess the moon
landing was kind of go hand in hand the
Flat Earth is a moon I I asked him that
some of this is where it gets tricky is
it like yeah this is where it gets
tricky some of them think yes some of
them think no some of them don't know I
think it's like a celestial body you
placed there by the Creator okay and uh
there's work it's this is where it gets
weird some some of them say the Stars
are angels ah some of them think they're
they are other other distant celestial
bodies super far off in the galaxy it's
it's the they all don't believe the same
thing yeah okay which is it which is
also interesting so it's like why why
take a stance on the earth it's
definitely around it's definitely flat
it's like why isn't it just I don't know
I've never been to space mmm they
haven't been to space ah much more fun
to put your foot down and just just
blame them in something yeah yeah yeah
cuz that's sort of me like I went in
very open art my friend Mike who was a
flat earther and so and he convinced me
to go so I went in open-armed and you
know made my conclusion at the end but I
tried to I tried to be very accepting of
what they believe yeah it's interesting
interesting people to meet do they know
who you were like were they familiar oh
yeah yeah one of them one of them left
oh really
one of one of the the main speakers left
whoa like mid speech like oh no no when
I remember when he when I had that no
when I uh when he found out I I was
there he he dipped he was supposed to
he's one of the main like Flat Earth
revolutionary leaders and yeah he found
out I was there and he dipped he was not
happy with my presence actually this is
some of you guys know this not everyone
on the internet likes me okay yeah it's
a kind of good segue to that cuz I want
to talk about that a little bit like we
encourage a lot of criticism on our
videos that we put out there because
that's you know at least in our belief
that's how we can become better
filmmakers yes yeah big facts yeah yeah
um no you obviously you're kind of at
the center of many different
you've been at the center of many
different controversy hurricanes you
know or like I quit it's like being the
heel and wrestling and how does how do
you how like how do you deal with that
like do you compartmentalize here like
public life in your private life do you
like but yeah I guess how do you deal
with the pressure in the criticism of
millions of people potentially you know
putting you at the focus of drama um yo
do what you got to do if if you want to
hate on me and attack someone online you
and it's got to be me like go for it
like that's not the kind of person I am
if that's you though if you feel like
you want to unleash your negative energy
today on someone like I can [ __ ]
handle a dog like I'm a tough guy
I could give a [ __ ] what anyone thinks
that's that's literally my entire brand
like be a [ __ ] maverick if I want to
be weird and different I'm gonna do it
I'm perfectly comfortable in my own skin
being myself and at the end of the day
there is I find extreme comfort in
knowing that like I am a good dude
and I told you this like I good morals
most of the time great energy and I and
I try to pass that on and and bring
happiness to the people around me so
it's not it's not like I have much to
worry about if I was like an actual
actually a piece of [ __ ] and at the end
of the day like I look at myself in the
mirror and I've had to do this before
right and momentarily not permanently
talking about like overall life Logan
Paul essence that'd be a problem but you
know people telling me yeah go die you
know you're a piece of [ __ ] scum of the
earth or like I could give a [ __ ] like
hmm sure I could I could never see
myself saying that about someone mm-hmm
I think people are so quick to rush to
conclusions and judge nowadays and I am
so far above and beyond that I'm here to
inspire and make people happy not put
people
even if they even if they quite honestly
do deserve to be put down like unless
it's my place and I feel very strongly
about something man I'm not here to
condemn people so how do you how do you
keep that from keeping you awake at
night for example how do you keep that
from getting to you and getting you down
sometimes it does and something when and
when it does um like with the Japan
thing I [ __ ] up
something needed to change my life I
needed a [ __ ] slap in the face and
and I'm not just saying that like I
needed a even now even right now to this
day I am still like finding myself
jumping into the mindset I was in then
and I'm like whoa hmm stop stop stop
that needed to happen so when I am
losing sleep about it or when I am
looking in the mirror and uh finding
myself questioning Who I am then it's
like okay these millions of people are
saying something to me and it's time to
listen
and so I do and so I do I make the
necessary changes some of which are
still ongoing to this day is specific
with specifically with the Japan thing a
year a year later now just just over a
year it's like I'm I'm I'm still
everyday working to become better but
like damn I look back in my videos and
it's very clear to me that I was just in
a place of [ __ ] recklessness just
nonsense there was no there was no
thinking
mmm-hmm everything was automated and
there was no no sense of empathy it was
go go go create create create bigger
better faster and it's it was just a
downward downward spiral of a [ __ ]
in danger you know but yeah man as far
as like hatred and [ __ ] like [ __ ] like I
got I have millions of fans that do love
me and appreciate my work and and know
who I am and like those are the people
that bec keep me going and shout-out
loading a [ __ ] love like I [ __ ]
love y'all dude and yeah they're there
they're the they're the ones like my my
fans are our good people they're there
they got smiles on their faces they're
here they're here to inspire and create
and achieve the goals they want to
achieve and
again that's a that's the type of person
I want watching my stuff not the liberal
on Twitter who wants to complain about
everything because they want to get
retweets in favor it's like [ __ ] off I
don't care about that mm-hmm so you got
the gang glow gang dedicated yeah to you
everything that you do right so and then
you have everyone else who's hating and
and complaining and and and all this
right so would you say that the world's
view of you is different than your view
of yourself when you say the world do
you mean the low game cuz the users
describe to group so low gang or the
haters a second one the haters okay so I
don't I don't think the haters are
haters true haters like they might not
like me they definitely most certainly
don't stand by things I've done I don't
stand by things I've done we're on the
same page I think just like just like I
have done ignorant things in my life and
ignorant has led to my downfall many
times again trying to cut back on that
um I think they're ignorant on who Logan
Paul is leads to a misinformed
calculation of of their assessment of me
so currently they are a hater but like
at the end of the day I'm not here to
piss people off I'm here to joke around
have a good time inspire motivate and
and create content yeah the Internet so
I think it's um I think it's ignorant
son like you I'm I'm sure you know this
uh this effect I'll say something I'll
do something the clip is taken posted on
Twitter no one has any context about the
thing and people make their judgments
assessments Logan Paul hate train begins
on to the next subject
[ __ ] Logan Paul until the next time you
[ __ ] up mmm-hmm they're not watching
the podcasts every day in between and
hearing the things I have to say they're
not watching the vlogs they're not
listening to me motivate millions of
kids to go out and achieve their dreams
like they don't because they don't care
they don't let the good things I do like
know they don't care about the good
things it's like I said you're the heel
I'm the heel broad it's one day me I get
it God do you think you want to hate go
for it you actually you brought
something interesting in your talking
last night where you talked about how
you know it's not like you can look at
somebody else who's doing what you're
doing
like it's not somebody else she's done
the same thing it's kind of paired away
it's no blueprint bro
yeah so do do you wish you had a mentor
or something that you could like look up
to that's kind of like pave the way
first or do you prefer kind of being out
there and taking the punches sometimes
yeah I wish I had a mentor I really do
and I've had some four different aspects
of my life but Dawg you name me one
[ __ ] youtuber who does become a
boxer is diving in the music is a
director is launching business ventures
multi-million dollar business ventures
started his own clothing line like you
can't do it because they don't exist six
successfully is the key because so far
I've been successful in 90% of the
things that I've done or started and
there's no blueprint for it I have this
saying my friend Andy shouts Andy he
told this to me he said he said he goes
you know don't be don't be a pioneer
everybody oh you're the you're the
pioneer in your field great good for you
he goes don't be a pioneer be a
Buccaneer when the Pioneers came over to
America
they were riddled with disease thousands
of them died because they had no idea
coming to this new land Indians
slaughtered them granted like that
subject specifically the pioneers
definitely slaughter the Indians and
that's a whole nother issues life yes
it's hard it's I mean yes it's a hard
life being a pioneer you the first one
to do something you know what you're
getting into and of the day you get
[ __ ] you all die the buccaneers came
second they knew what to expect that
came with their protective clothes to
knock it bit by bit by mosquitos into a
weapons to bring and they knew they came
with a mission and a mindset the
Buccaneers were the one who's ones who
succeeded and eventually formed what is
now known as America but it don't be a
pioneer be a Buccaneer unfortunately I
am a pioneer so I'm gonna be the one
making the mistakes and doing everything
that is new and breaking that new ground
I'm blessed to do it I'm blessed to do
it I would I would have in no other way
but it would
be nice to have a mentor who's done
something similar because dude I'm this
year I'm so focused on growth and
knowledge and wisdom and you're 23 right
yeah so you big scheme of things well
even in the small scheme of things
you're young yeah still young yeah but
I'm almost 24 man I'm turning 24 in like
three months oh yeah I'm getting older
dude so when you say you're you're in
the pursuit of growth knowledge wisdom
like what does that mean do you have
specific areas you're trying to work out
at or like just generally everything or
what does it mean to you it's it's it's
everything yeah I I think the more
wisdom I can absorb from people from all
walks of life which is part of the
reason I love doing my podcast so much
is because I get to talk to all sorts of
fascinating people and I'm gonna try and
even diversify more the better for me
and because I think I do
I really think knowledge is power like I
I agree like I graduated high school
with like a 4.0 GPA full academic right
at college I'm a [ __ ] nerd bro like
math and science are my [ __ ] and and
that was what that it could and combined
with being an athlete was the thing that
always made me excel and succeed so I
think now man it can you imagine can you
imagine like mmm 99% of people who don't
like me think I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they're like oh that's the kid who'd
know yeah what's going on what's Bob
they think I'm an idiot
they watch the podcast and every comment
you are like I really don't like Logan
Paul but this is like this is really
entertaining I really like this podcast
this is like a side of him I haven't
seen before because I get to use my
brain and talk and like be articulate
about things that I've done intrigue me
so
can you imagine if I become this ultra
well-versed human being who has got a
plethora of knowledge in all sorts of
different fields and I can speak on
subjects without being ignorance or
ignorant man I would that was sure
surprised people I think yeah I look I
look forward to that day where I can wow
people with my intelligence so I don't
know about you but like you know
obviously when the cameras on me I'm I'm
elevated right I'm a bit of a different
person on camera even now even now you
seem pretty relaxed now your Niko yeah I
mean but this is looking pretty Niko
pretty me code right now no I'm so I
mean a little bit different now like
usually you know if if the cameras
weren't on I would be a little more
rambley and a little more loose of who
I'm saying but or now I'm more focused
mmm you know what things change a little
bit hmm
um now with you like do you how do you
change when the cameras aren't rolling
business when they are like right now
versus it's 10:00 p.m. you're sitting in
bed or you're just hanging out with
somebody having dinner like what is what
is Logan on camera versus Logan off
camera the impulsive Logan I'm at my
podcast is is is oh that's that's the
closest one you'll probably see online
uh even now like I'm pretty focused
pretty serious bro in real life I'm a
[ __ ] nut granted you want to hop into
like a serious conversation I'm all for
it I love that [ __ ] there's nothing I
find more satiating than
conversation but obviously in the vlogs
talking about bringing a lot of [ __ ]
energy which I can do and I is a part of
me like it's it's a 50% of Logan take
from the vlogs 50% of Logan take from
the podcast that's that's me off-camera
you know um I still have a hella hella
energy but also can be like a human
being sometimes so good yeah was it like
end of 2018 you stop doing the daily
vlogs right yeah so how about now what
does it ever you how often are you doing
vlogs zero really you comment back a
little gang they're coming back but uh
yeah because I just got my tonsils out
man I can't do [ __ ] gotcha
I had sex the other day I started
bleeding on my mouth and next morning
twice [ __ ] [ __ ] with actor told me
sorry doctor she told me not to have sex
and I did I mean why are you bleeding on
your mouth cuz the toss was bro that's
supposed to get your blood pressure high
the breathing like no no no no no no no
no it's it was the next morning it
didn't have it didn't happen in the
moment it's it's cuz the blood pressure
raises and then I think the scab I don't
I don't know bro it's wack as [ __ ]
did they give you ice cream yeah they
gave me ice cream padam - I am two weeks
out then I am two weeks and one that 15
days out and I'm still bleeding I'm a
[ __ ] mouth bro the surgery sucks or
I've been able to do [ __ ] but the vlogs
going back I'm gonna do two a week to
answer your question that's what i'ma do
um I want to find a way to elevate them
and also like be myself more um I I put
this in my end of your recap videos i go
when i when i started youtube i want to
want wanted to inject the vlogs with as
much energy as I possibly could that was
the mindset and now it's like okay I
know I have I know people like me so I
don't have to put on a persona as much
as I thought maybe I I did I'm still
going to because you know vlogs are in
my opinion supposed to be the most fun
energizing
part of the audience's day so I want to
bring it all to them what I am going to
be
a little more a little more of myself
that's good
yeah yeah I think so yeah you know I had
a question for you hit me bro
so you know something like you you got a
huge following you're successful thanks
man you're welcome
mm-hmm you know you're probably set
financially etc you're at this center of
a charisma in power bubble right yeah so
how does someone like that go about
making friends like how do you how do
you make friends when you have so many
other factors at play it that could
easily taint a relationship like that
yeah it's a great question the answer is
[ __ ] making friends do you have any
friends yeah hell yeah
but [ __ ] making more like yo my circle
is tight and he's been tight for a while
every friend I've had in my life has
been my friend for a minute the closest
or the the newest friend that I've made
I've known him for two years his name is
Andy he's like the newest like real
tight-knit friend like who I text on the
Reg but like what I don't there is never
an attempt to like minute go make
friends it's always some sort of
miraculous chain of events the stars
aligned and for some reason I run into
this human being who I I click with on a
very spiritual energetic level rat that
is there is just a there's just a
connection immediately mm-hmm so yeah
[ __ ] making new friends I'm I'm not like
a hundred percent against it but you can
imagine dude I have no idea people's
intentions when they meet me or who who
who they are trying to be in order to
like impress me I don't know if they
want to get in my content whatever it is
like everyone who I've ended up making
friends with it happens some sort of
weird way and it's the most organic
thing possible so how did I end up
becoming your friend like all the other
people out there yeah so Andy
my brother Jake invited me on a trip to
Italy to go pick up Lamborghinis we were
gonna buy and Jake's videographer Kade
has a girlfriend named McKenzie and she
said her brother Andy speaks fluent
Italian and they have like a villa up
there so we were gonna go to this guy
Andy's place and and I met Andy and
within the first five seconds I was like
whoa
you always dude is cool like this dudes
I really like him I don't really like
like most people like we don't like it's
not it's not that I don't like people I
love people it's like I rarely feel this
way about someone immediately yeah and
and those when I feel that way about
someone like right off the bat it tends
to be a long-lasting friendship you
think it has something to do with like
traveling and being away from home being
away from work I mean maybe it was a
work thing for you going to you know
filming the vlog doing the cars and
whatnot in Italy but like would you say
that traveling you your walls were a bit
brought down though no I think there was
definitely an atmosphere sure that was
like magical fun Italy and we were all
like having a good time sure but I think
this dude Andy gives off an energy like
that is phenomenal I can relate it to
myself in many ways we just clicked we
we vibed and connected like I said as I
do with most of my friends and even
every every girl I've had a lasting
relationship with it's the same way
within the first within the first hour
two hours there's a there's something
where I'm like II feel a certain way
about this this chicks and whether it's
like yo she's like really cool we really
connect and I enjoy by conversing with
her which is again like I I could give a
[ __ ] about conversing with most people
with dog to be honest with you but if
I'm stimulated like I'm good I love that
that's I thrive in that that's why I
even like on my podcast like again like
it starts Ari keep plugging my podcast
but like I love doing it cuz like I'm
mentally stimulated
for like an hour to an hour-and-a-half
just talking about things that intrigue
me and I love that hmm interesting yeah
so how about your brother like do you
have a pretty close relationship with
your brother I love Jake yeah yeah he's
my best friend so yes very close so you
know when when corridor starting and
when Freddy W was starting you know I
saw I saw Freddy and Jimmy you know for
those of you don't know Jimmy is
Freddy's brother Jimmy hates me I
probably guess that yeah how do you know
um
he's he's tweeted a lot at me and it's
and uh they were they were powerful
tweets and they got a lot of retweets
and he I think he went hard on the the
disrespect towards Asians mmm that's
that's what he that's what he folks not
to derail you for a second but Jimmy I
do want to if you're watching this I
want to try to settle this dog because I
think you're dope and I believe in you
and I I know your acting career is
taking off and it's a little
disheartening because you know I grew up
watching Freddie Wong and obviously
Jimmy - there was the video game high
school thing he was great great in that
and so I made this mistake in Japan and
in surrounding the thing in Japan is me
just being culturally insensitive and I
think a lot of people mistook that as
something have against the Asian
community not the case they're just
being an [ __ ] in general I just
happened to be in Japan my my
ex-girlfriend is half asian like I've no
qualms against any race or anyone in in
general this years about relationships
or series about love and uh Jimmy I'm
here to say I love you we'll send this
podcast to Jimmy thank you so but where
I'm going with that is that I saw so I
saw Freddie and Jimmy both growing up in
their careers at least in the early
stages trying to like find their way
where they're both kind of in a similar
realm you know and Freddie was obviously
blowing up with the Freddie W channel
which then became a rocket jump and
Jimmy was you know finding his own way
but like there was a little bit of
attention at least that I sensed where
it's a little bit sibling rivalry and
they were supporting each other too but
at which point can you be independent
versus relying on your sibling for
support
and I'm wondering you know do you and
Jake have similar issues that you deal
with like where do you like support him
to the point where he also wants to be
independent or vice versa and is there a
rivalry between you guys versus you guys
being very supportive of each other like
what is that relationship like yeah
there was there was absolutely there was
that that phase where we were the
fledgling youtubers who wanted to be the
best and when I was running the YouTube
race I would look to my right see no
competition I look to my left and see no
competition waitis again yeah is that my
[ __ ] brother he was the only one you
know so of course there's an inherent
rivalry and in the Jake and Logan Paul
feud and it became what it became nasty
[ __ ]
there was the diss tracks the whole the
whole wave of him trying to up the bar
me trying the up the bar like actual
physical like pranks and denouncing each
other on the vlogs it was uh it was bad
and then when he failed immensely and
then I failed immensely we both reached
the conclusion that this is [ __ ]
stupid this is my brother no one in the
world will have my back ever more than
that human being right there or
understand where we came from and what
we're doing now and how those are
interconnected no one knows that no
one's been through that journey other
than Jake you know I talked about not
having a blueprint for the [ __ ] I do and
me not having like a mentor or a guide
to follow
neither does Jake like he's got me and
I've got him man so at the end of the
day we outgrew that [ __ ] it's old like I
said the love is going to connect Jake
and I our whole entire lives and there's
no reason to sacrifice that because of
some internet [ __ ] money fame
whatever it is [ __ ] that man I don't
care I'm over that [ __ ] like I'm 23
years old now I feel like I've lived ten
[ __ ] lives I've I've
failed over and over and over again and
succeeded over and over and over again
and so has Jake and like I said man
there's no one there's no one who I love
more in this world than Jake and and
it's probably probably this I hope it's
the same for him to me man and we just
outgrew it we outgrew it to answer your
question it's good yeah I think that's
honestly really healthy it is it's the
hell it's the hell that's why even when
like when I don't know how much y'all
are involved like actually like YouTube
culture but like when ksi and edgy are
feuding like I had desi on my podcast
partially to piss ksi off because [ __ ]
that guy but also uh they're like to
actually like maybe urged edgy to to
settle this thing that we're doing cuz
it's not healthy dude I don't I don't
wish it upon any family to for for
brothers to to be fighting like and
settling it on the internet man that is
[ __ ] like why why publicly you know like
that doesn't need to be public it's like
and they went deep they went that's
interesting to me man it's like they
know it's gonna get views and I think
YouTube drama people know it's gonna get
views so I mean what is it like what are
you like are you gonna go down the drama
route and try and know that that's like
you know successful and money or are you
just gonna be like hey I need I should
rather have a personal conversation with
this person over here because that's
just more humane
you just got to draw the line and I
think desi specifically not so much ksi
as much as I hate to say I do think ksi
is wiser than and edgy in the sense of
he's older and edgy wasn't very and
chicken I call it like tunnel vision
mode look you don't you don't really
think about the repercussions
you see views you see money see
subscribers you see your community
rallying behind you and and slapping you
on the ass and saying no like you're
right no you got this and so you get a
little bit bit of an ego next thing you
know you're making a [ __ ] diss track
on your own brother and it gets nasty
hmm so when you when you're saying like
I would earlier like maybe like 30
minutes ago you're saying you know I
would never say like I hate this person
blah blah blah blah now with the with
the boxing match
like you guys were going at it I really
disliked hairs I okay so I made it clear
I said like I try hard unless I really
truly believe in something I try hard
not to denounce people unless I really
truly believe in it I've I really
dislike ASI why he took our feud are fun
YouTube feud to a level of utmost
disrespect you talk about me being the
heel of YouTube during our fight and the
narrative of Logan Paul last year ksi
became the heel a lot of my fans a lot
of the internet a lot of people just
watching you know the press conferences
and stuff watched and exited with the
belief that this dude ksi is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] he talks [ __ ] about my family
talk [ __ ] about my girlfriend he mocked
me and some of the most vulnerable times
of my life
and by the way these are things I asked
him not to do no I texted him personally
I'm like yo remember that contract we
sign where it said I wouldn't bring up
your sexual harassment issues in the
past and you wouldn't bring up Japan
just so we could like move forward and
not make this a very toxic situation for
all the fans to enjoy and also so
YouTube doesn't by the way
nitch our our our clip clip the entire
fight because they're the ones they're
hosting it on YouTube completely ignored
that asked him to leave Chloe out of it
completely ignored that yeah it was just
he there was
there was too many shots below the bell
for me to sit here and say like I
respect this guy and even after the
fight after the fight
talking seconds after it's a draw
unfortunately I asked him I'm like oh
not it like we did this once you know
we're gonna do this again next time just
like man the man mind you were both
[ __ ] sweating can't even think eyes
are red bruises on her face in horrible
condition I'm like next time like yo
let's leave let's leave like the person
who like girlfriend stuff out of it you
know it's like let's be a little
classier like would you be down for that
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's like he goes yeah
man yeah nah you know it's just the game
man it's just the way it's just what it
is what it is you know and I'm like bro
like my girls like a real girl at the
time you know she's not my girlfriend
anymore but she's a real girl she has
feelings she has a career you did not
deserve to say her name and I'm asking
nicely
to not do that like and we just beat the
[ __ ] out of each other you think next
time we can like be a little classier
about this whole situation man
I can't imagine the [ __ ] that's gonna
come out of his mouth in my mouth for
the next couple press conferences in for
the next fight I know what I'm gonna say
I have I have a lot of ammunition now
okay yeah here's the thing is like he
steps it up right he's going below the
belt you feel the need to do the same
yeah well that's the thing that's the
thing I'm just I just got not just got
over the Japan thing but here's me
trying to be like a like a stand out guy
I'm like okay I'm gonna change and be
like a I'm gonna I'm gonna try to be a
good guy now and you know chaos I didn't
start saying things they're like I don't
like and so then I have to start saying
things that I don't like about him and
that that don't reflect upon me well
like do you think you need to step down
to that level
uh-hmm because it's entertaining yes and
I'm a sucker for being an entertainer
bro like I just love to edit like
unfortunately it's what people want like
the juicier and the deeper I can dig my
knife into into the drama like
unfortunately yes people like that [ __ ]
so I'm gonna do it god Bless America and
yes there's no I don't have to I just
I'm probably going to here's the issue
here's why it might not happen it's not
much
much left to say about me hmm all the
bases are covered he pulled every punch
he could there's not much left to roast
me on so you want to bring up the past
live okay that's we get it been talked
about but we talked about I got new I
got new material bro so you would rather
entertain as opposed to change the
dialogue yes yeah I mean we'll see we'll
see I say that now I just like I love
the fans so I want to give him what they
want where I want to give him something
to talk about a dinner man that's me
what would you do if you couldn't
entertain like if there's not YouTube
I'd be so my goal before I before I
started YouTube I wanted to create a
product that would revolutionize the
world I was a engineer studying
engineering in college and I wanted to
create something that would change
change the face of human existence like
Elon Musk type shoe deal on yes yeah
yeah yeah so uh didn't happen found a
video camera and [ __ ] Oh Here I am
huh looking back where's the first point
we're like hey this is blowing up
it was like it was on vine it was on
line there's no others they were is
literally no feeling better than that of
your first post going viral mm-hmm and
you're like whoa this is really
something man I remember I had like 400
followers on vine I made this vine this
guy named Austin Miles Jeter Jeter
retweeted it or refined it as revenge
revine at the time and you know an hour
later I had two thousand followers dawg
um I was hot [ __ ] I was a big man on
campus bro everyone in my town knew who
I was or so I thought I go to Chipotle
and Here I am like you know cover my
face expect to get like mob I mean no
one gave a [ __ ] or do who I was like no
one knew who I was but here I am with
2,000 followers like this is incredible
this is amazing you know God with the
10k thank God I feel like 27 k then met
this guy named Jerome Jarre he flew me
out to New York and made contact with
him got to 100k benchmark benchmark
benchmark next thing you know hopping to
Instagram Facebook 50 million fans on
Facebook making sketches and when those
posts would go viral like I'm sure
you've seen like splitting the world
dabbing at the Olympics like just these
funny crazy viral sketch videos there's
such an adrenaline rush of me my full
passion the thing I love most in life is
creating I love it but what can be that
nice little sprinkle a nice little
cherry on top
if the things that I create are received
well and people enjoy them that is
that's it me bro that's the cake I love
that [ __ ] cuz creating is fun mmm it's
[ __ ] dope oh that's great but I'm not
sure I'd be doing it if there wasn't
people saying I like it dude that's very
good that's a very interesting point I
thought the same thing without YouTube
without social media like what I still
be creating probably in some other way
like I play drums up in my yeah in the
Attic you know no one's really seeing
that and that's that's fun but I I got
into it because I want to make films you
know yeah I want to make like awesome
stories to awesome stories that get
people feeling a certain way and like
that's so much fun to me that's cool
aren't people to feel a certain way then
you have no reason to create an art it's
it's interesting it's interesting cuz I
mean you say you have no reason to
create an art and it's it's like you
know what is your reason which I've had
asked myself also is my reason cuz I
truly love it yes but also a thing I
love may be equally as much as that it
is received and people enjoy it and it
makes them happy it affects them it
actually affects the way they feel which
is [ __ ] so it's dope yeah I think that
drives for much anybody in kind of like
our arena of what we do at least and
that's and that's and that's why we
don't stop by the way I think too is
like and as long as you got people
commenting and saying yo I love this
this is crazy this inspires me this is
hilarious people texting me that video
you put out today's dope I like when you
make this point I'm gonna be here for a
minute bro Logan Paul is cancelled but
I'm gonna be here for a minute so when
you do something you love and you are
doing it as a job you risk turning what
you love into a job so how do you keep
creating stuff from becoming work to the
point we don't like doing it anymore
um very lucky and I've said there's a
lies mmm rarely feel like I'm working
[Music]
and the thing my work is my play you
know I I don't really do much besides
grind because that's the thing that
makes me happy luckily however when I
hit that point where I have to like take
a second look around that I'm like oh
this is feeling like work this is no
longer fun to me pulled up look pull
that [ __ ] plug I have the luxury to
pull that plug because you know I am
financially secure I'm happy elsewhere
in my life like I not a lot of people
can do that I'm very fortunate enough
where I can like stop doing something
and and switch my focus or something
else if that thing is no longer making
me happy mm-hmm granted I've been there
in my life where you can't pull that
plug and you got a bike that [ __ ]
bullet and example train four hours a
day for five months to become a boxer to
fight some kid that you don't even care
about you just dislike like I've been
there to to sit through hours and hours
of studying to get an a-plus on the test
because I know I know if I keep getting
A's and get a good score on my AC T I'll
get a full ride to to college because my
parents can't afford them themselves
like mm-hmm bite that bullet and and sit
through and do what you got to do if you
need to unfortunately for me again I
don't I don't have to so I try to always
keep my work my play and when it doesn't
end up becoming like that like with the
vlogs for example the daily vlog I was
at a serious point I was like this [ __ ]
is making me depressed I am no longer
happy I'm under a microscope I can't do
this anymore
I was just the I need I needed some
creative spin now we got impulsive now
I've got a full feature film documentary
about the flat earth yeah yeah
interesting I think I think a nice note
to kind of circle back to and maybe wrap
things up on two questions really so
away at the beginning of the vlog we
talked about being a good guy I'm
curious for you how do you define that
how how would you suggest people be a
good person
that's a great question how would I
suggest people be a good person
I would really urge people
to try to empathize more
think that's lost I lost it last year
even know if I ever had it to be honest
with you growing up I don't know if I
was ever taught true empathy which think
is poor part of my inherent problem and
even now it's like I'm not [ __ ]
perfect I make this very clear I'm not
perfect but I try to empathize as much
as I can
[Music]
see something happening on Twitter
example let's use that other couldn't
make America great again had who was
confronted by that uh Native American
protester do you know about this story
yeah you said him as an example like you
know the first narrative that came out
is the the mega kid in disrespecting an
elder i sat back for a second didn't put
my tweet out although a couple of my
friends were like oh you should you
should [ __ ] say something about this
this kid is like he could be in the low
gang and like this is like a danger this
is very dangerous what's happening I'm
like okay let's hold the beat let's wait
one second before I I denounce this kid
and and tell him that he's a piece of
[ __ ] for smirking in this this natives
face with by the way no context or
anything about the event like that's
what a stupid person would do quite
honestly like I believe that's what
someone who was trying to get retweets
and favorites and be a leader for their
community would do right off the bat
story develops turns out there was some
african-american demonstrator hurling
racial slurs at this group of white kids
which is completely inappropriate and
uncalled for I don't know how much
backstory you know I did my research and
and then this Native American protester
hopped in started banging his drum in a
song of peace no one knows this is a
song of peace besides his Native
American friends the kids don't know
that so the one kid just stood there
like a jackass he wanted to be cool in
front of his friends and stand his
ground in in in front of this Native
American protester and then didn't there
was no build a wall chance according to
the video it was it was it was just a
weird situation where like the narrative
was turned into a kid trying to be
racist and be disrespectful to an elder
was it disrespectful yeah the kid look
like a [ __ ] jackass he's a prick but
like okay they don't need a foot find
his name send letters to the college he
applied to in ruin his whole life
because of a like come on the kids he's
a human let's empathize with him for a
second he's [ __ ] what sixteen
seventeen he's know what the [ __ ] he's
doing he's just he's just being an
a-hole so what like I was an [ __ ]
when I was sixteen I'm still awesome
sometimes like so I can I just I would
just urge people to try to empathize
more and think critically before you
make assessments or judgments on people
through your research I say this all the
time here
investigate before before you hop to a
conclusion about something that's all
and and and hmm
try to split try to spread good good
energy like keep it keep your vibes
positive as much as you can I know it's
hard but like we got a very happy
household because we're all very candid
with each other and we all love what we
do and surround yourself with the right
people you'll be good let's get one yeah
like good ones I got one more question
let's do it let's get this bread let's
get this [ __ ] bread what's uh what's
your secret to success oh man I gotta I
gotta attribute this to my work ethic
dude man there's a that's the that's the
that's the core of it cuz like I do have
I do have something innate in me there's
that is that is the the talent that
whether that's uh whether it can be
characterized by the creativity or
ability in in entered the entertainment
world to to entertain but
you know they say hard work beats talent
first when I came to LA I didn't believe
that you see these rappers like they
[ __ ] smoke and sip lean all day they
make one song a month and it pops off
and sure that's a good lifestyle for a
year or two they ain't gonna last hey it
will not be here for a long time it's
about longevity bro so yeah I'm gonna be
a hard worker for the rest of my life
that will never stop my work ethic in
Grain to be in me by my father and
growing up 18 years in Ohio trying my
best to get a full ride to college
whether it's gonna be academic or
athletic can be attributed to the number
one key factor behind my success you got
to work your [ __ ] ass off if you want
it how bad you [ __ ] want it if you
really want it go get it no excuses go
get that [ __ ] and you'll be met with
roadblocks that's life welcome welcome
to life thanks for joining us on this
podcast but push through it and get over
it do it Logan thanks coming out joins
us of course thank you yeah is there
anything you want to people to check out
of yours no just get your March bro shot
movement give this bread all right man
thank you so much voice breaks Logan of
course officiated me thank you for
joining us on the corridor cast that was
a fascinating conversation to look and
Paul Logan if you're listening thank you
for joining us we really appreciate it
and if you guys aren't subscribed to the
corridor cast YouTube channel head on
over there and do so and I'd love to
hear some comments from you guys on who
you would like us to get to join us as
guests what would you like us to talk
about heck I'd love to see some
conversation here on what we talked
about in this podcast do you agree with
the things that we were saying you agree
or disagree with the things that Logan
was saying there's been a lot of great
discourse in the comments in the past
and it's one of my favorite things to
read and participate in so please head
on over there and do so and you can find
the quarter cast on any other audio
platform that has podcasts so you can
find hopefully your favorite podcasts on
your favorite podcast listening channels
yeah yeah maybe I don't need to be in
the intro and outro clavia sure I needed
you as emotional support because be
right here it's long everybody bye-bye